good evening
it is the holiday season specifically
on the day that i will be releasing this
it is christmas day
which is
one of the most important
holidays and or
days in general for christians around
the world at least western christians
catholics and protestants some of you
may not be celebrating christmas others
maybe
but
in any case you can't deny that it is an
important day of the year for many
people around the world
and i've seen a lot of people on youtube
lately do special christmas episodes and
of course i'm also going to deliver at
least in some sense
i won't be able to do a full
video in the format that i usually do
here but i'm going to give you at least
something for
christmas or the holiday season this
year as most of you probably know
christmas is the time of year when
christians celebrate the birth of jesus
christ who is considered by christians
to be the son and the holy trinity and
thus the incarnation of god's word
in human form
the person who
brought salvation to humankind through
his suffering and death on the cross etc
this it's all very well known of course
and the birth of this figure is of
course very important that it's
celebrated around the world in different
ways of course it is celebrated on today
on december 25th in most of the sort of
western christian world whereas in many
of the orthodox churches it's celebrated
later in
january but the purpose of the day
remains the same to celebrate the
supposed birth of jesus and this can of
course mean different things to
different people different
interpretations and symbolic
understandings of what this birth is
supposed to mean
and one of what i think the most
fascinating and
striking ways of looking at christmas
comes from the very famous uh 14th and
13th century mystic christian mystic
meister eckhart
i made a full video on maester eckhart
about a year ago actually also i think
on december 25th last year and he is one
of the most important figures in the
history of christian mysticism but he is
also controversial because he proposed
certain ideas about god and in the
relationship of god to the soul and
creation that to some people seemed a
little out of line and certain of his
um claims certain of certain quotes from
his works and sermons were later deemed
heretical after his death but today he
has sort of regained his reputation as a
very important
person in church history
now eckhart taught very significantly
that
the
ground he talks about this thing he
calls the ground the grunt in german
which is this sort of innermost essence
or
foundation
of god to begin with like right he talks
about the grunt the ground of god but
what is significant is that he also says
that
the ground of god is the ground of the
soul they are one and the same ground so
he proposes that in the innermost
essence of the human soul
she is one and completely unified with
god
himself right and that god is
in everything that god is
this the only reality there is nothing
outside of god god is the very being of
everything that exists and there's a
whole lot more to eckhart's theology of
course and you can watch my full video
on that if you're interested now based
on that very mystical
and beautiful really fascinating
philosophy he also talks about the birth
of the word or birth of the sun right
which is what christmas is all about and
so he interprets christmas the
celebration of the birth of the son of
god
in
regular fashion as he always does he
interprets it very metaphysically you
could say and he talks about the fact
that the sun
is being born eternally inside the
godhead the unity of god and of course
usually when we talk about christmas we
think of the birth of jesus the human
being who is the incarnation of the word
and that is also one aspect of christmas
to eckhart but eckhart sees many
different
dimensions you could say of what
christmas symbolizes on the one hand of
course it does symbolize the birth of
the human jesus but also
what he is much more interested in he
barely actually mentions the human jesus
in any of his sermons about this topic
um he instead
talks a lot more about the more
metaphysical and psychological aspects
of this
event this birth of the sun in the
ground of god in the unity of god and
the godhead which is taking place
eternally
in this eternal present now if you
remember what i said earlier that the
ground the very ground grunt of god is
one and unified with the ground of the
soul this also means that the birth of
the sun birth of christ or the word is
taking place in the soul of the human
being also at all times and this becomes
very significant for eckhart and becomes
one of the primary symbols for a kind of
heightened and mystical awareness and
consciousness the absolute
mystical experience of the unity with
with god you could say
is this experience of
this birth of the sun in the soul of
oneself that is always taking place but
one can realize that when one completely
empties
the
self of any connection to outside things
when one annihilates any sense of
self understanding when one abandons all
forms of knowing either of outside
things or of one's self until the soul
is a complete
blank slate
one is in a state of complete
nothingness right
one has annihilated oneself
so that there's nothing left and one
just in this complete abyss of the
darkness of the soul
and in that state is when the birth of
the sun the birth of the word can take
place within the soul
and this is a very important symbol then
for eckhart for
this
this process of of spiritual
uh spiritual development or spiritual
awakening of realizing one's oneness
with god and uniting with god so
as you can tell this is a very unique
way of looking at christmas it's not the
the the interpretation of christmas that
you'll hear from
your regular sunday service of course
but it's one that i find incredibly
fascinating
eckhart was a writer he wrote many
treatises in latin
about you know commentaries on biblical
books etc but he was primarily famous as
an incredible preacher he would preach
primarily to
to other monks
and friars of the dominican order but
also sometimes to the lay people as well
and he was known as a really gifted
preacher whose sermons a lot of them at
least survived to this day and four of
those sermons are
were held or were given in christmas
season so they talk about christmas
and the way that this way that i've just
explained how he interprets christmas
as in this very mystical and
metaphysical way so what i thought i
would do
for this christmas season is that i
would read you one of those christmas
sermons held by meister eckhart all
those
must be almost 800 years ago
now remember this is not me preaching
anything to you
if you watch this channel you know where
i stand on things i'm not here to
this is not a confessional video in that
sense
i'm not preaching i'm not reading you
eckhart sermon in order that you are
supposed to
necessarily believe in what he says it's
more from a perspective of
appreciation and of
studying these fascinating figures of
history and the way that they express
themselves and their very unique ideas
eckhart sermons are
fascinating to read
regardless if you're christian or if
you're from any other religious
tradition i think one can appreciate
the depth of his philosophical thoughts
and mystical ideas and also
just see how incredible of a rhetorician
he was and how captivating these sermons
must have been for those who attended
them
so
with that said this is one of the
sermons held at christmas
by meister eckhart possibly on december
25th on christmas day
many many years ago
where is he who was born king of the
jews
now observe as regards to this birth
where it takes place
where is he who is born
now i say as i often said before that
this eternal birth occurs in the soul
precisely as it does in eternity no more
and no less for it is one birth and this
birth occurs in the essence and ground
of the soul
now certain questions arise first of all
since god is in all things as
intelligence and is more truly in them
than they are in themselves and more
naturally and since wherever god is
there he must work knowing himself and
speaking his word
in what special respects then is the
soul better fitted for this divine
operation than are other rational
creatures in which god also is pay
attention to the explanation
god is in all things as being as
activity as power
but he is feckened in the soul alone for
though every creature is a vestige of
god the soul is the natural image of god
this image must be adorned and perfected
in this birth no creature but the soul
alone is receptive to this act this
birth indeed such perfection as enters
the soul whether it be divine undivided
light grace or bliss must enter the soul
through this birth and in no other way
just await this birth within you and you
shall experience all good and all
comfort all happiness all being and all
truth if you miss it you will miss all
good and blessedness
whatever comes to you in that will bring
you pure being and stability but
whatever you seek or cleave to part from
this will perish
take it how you will and where you will
all will perish
this alone gives being all else perishes
but in this birth you will share in the
divine influx and all its gifts
this cannot be received by creatures in
which god's image is not found for the
soul's image appertains especially to
this eternal birth which happens truly
and especially in the soul being
begotten of the father in the soul's
ground and innermost recesses into which
no image ever shun or soul power peeped
the second question is since this work
of birth occurs in the essence and
ground of the soul then it happens just
as much in a sinner as in a saint so
what grace or good is there in it for me
for the ground of nature is the same in
both in fact even those in hell retain
their nobility of nature eternally
now note the answer it is a property of
this birth that it always comes with
fresh light it always brings a great
light to the soul for it is the nature
of good to diffuse itself wherever it is
in this birth god streams into the soul
in such abundance of light so flooding
the essence and ground of the soul that
it runs over and floods into the powers
and into the outward man
thus it befell paul when on his journey
god touched him with his light and spoke
to him a reflection of the light shone
outwardly so that his companion saw it
surrounding paul like the blessed in
heaven
the superfluity of light in the ground
of the soul wells over into the body
which is filled with radiance
no sinner can receive this light nor is
he worthy to being full of sin and
wickedness
which is called darkness
therefore it says the darkness shall
neither receive nor comprehend the light
john 1 5
that is because the paths by which the
light would enter are choked and
obstructed with guile and darkness for
light and darkness cannot coexist or god
and creatures if god shall enter the
creatures must simultaneously go out
a man is fully aware of this light
directly he turns to god a light being
to gleam and glow within him
directly he turns to god a light begins
to gleam and glow within him giving him
to understand what to do and what to
leave undone with much true guidance in
regard to things of which before he knew
or understood nothing
and here supposedly one of the listeners
to eckhart
asks him a question in the middle of the
sermon where do you know this from and
in what way eckhart says just pay
attention your heart is often moved and
turned away from the world
how could that be but by this
illumination it is so charming and
delightful that you become wary of all
things that are not god or gods it draws
you to god and you become aware of many
a prompting to do good though ignorant
of whence it comes
this inward inclination is in no way due
to creatures or their bidding for what
creatures direct or effect always comes
from without
but by this work it is only the ground
of the soul that is stirred and the
freer you keep yourself the more light
truth and discernment you will find
thus no man ever went astray for any
other reason than that he first departed
from this and then sought too much to
cling to outward things
saint augustine says there are many who
sought light and truth but only outside
where it was not to be found
finally they go out so far that they
never get back home or find their way in
again
thus they have not found the truth for
truth is within in the ground and not
without
so he who would see light to discern all
truth let him watch and become aware of
this birth within in the ground
then all his powers will be illuminated
and the outer man as well
for as soon as god inwardly stirs the
ground with truth its light darts into
his powers and that man knows at times
more than anyone could teach him
as the prophet says quote i have gained
greater understanding than all who ever
taught me you see then because this
light cannot shine or lighten in sinners
that is why this birth cannot possibly
occur in them this birth cannot coexist
with the darkness of sin even though it
takes place not in the powers but in the
essence and ground of the soul
the question arises since god the father
gives birth only in the essence and
ground of the soul and not in the powers
what concern is it of theirs how do they
help just by being idle and taking a
rest
what is the use since this birth does
not take place in the powers a good
question listen well to the explanation
every creature works towards some end
the end is always the first in intention
but the last in execution
thus too god in all his works has a most
blessed end in view namely himself
to bring the soul and other powers into
that end himself
for this all god's works are wrought for
this the father bears his son in the
soul so that all the powers of the soul
shall come to this
he lies in weight for all that the soul
contains bidding all to this feast at
his court
but the soul is scattered abroad among
her powers and dissipated in the action
of each the power of sight in the eye
the power of hearing in the ear the
power of tasting in the tongue thus her
ability to work inwardly is enfeebled
for a scattered power is imperfect
so for her inward work to be effective
she must call in all her powers and
gather them together from the diversity
of things to a single inward activity
sin augustine says the soul is rather
where she loves than where she gives
life to the body
for example there was once a pagan
master who was devoted to an art that of
mathematics to which he had devoted all
his powers
he was sitting by the embers making
calculations and practicing his art when
a man came along who drew a sword and
not knowing that it was the master said
quick tell me your name or i'll kill you
the master was too absorbed to see or
hear the foe to catch what he said he
was unable to utter a word even to say
my name is so-and-so and so the enemy
having cried out several times and got
no answer cut off his head
and this was to acquire a mere natural
science how much more then should we
withdraw from all things in order to
concentrate all our powers on perceiving
and knowing the one infinite uncreated
eternal truth
to this end then assemble all your
powers all your senses your entire mind
and memory direct them into the ground
where your treasure lies buried
but if this is to happen realize that
you must drop all other works you must
come to an unknowing if you would find
it
the question arises would it not be more
valuable for each power to keep to its
own task not hindering the other in
their work nor god in his might there
not be in me a manner of creaturely
knowing that is not a hindrance just as
god knows all things without hindrance
and so to the blessed in heaven
that is a good question
note the explanation
the blessed see god in a single image
and in that image they discern all
things
god too sees himself thus perceiving all
things in himself
he need not turn from one thing to
another as we do
suppose in this life we always had a
mirror before us in which we saw all
things at a glance and recognized them
in a single image then neither action
nor knowledge would be any hindrance to
us but we have to turn from one thing to
another and so we can only attend to one
thing at the expense of another for the
soul is so firmly attached to the powers
that she has to flow with them wherever
they flow because in every task they
perform the soul must be present and
attentive or they cannot work at all
if she is dissipated by attending to
outward acts this is bound to weaken her
inward work
for at his birth god needs and must have
a vacant free and unencumbered soul
containing nothing but himself alone and
which looks to nothing and nobody but
him as to this christ says whoever loves
anything but me whoever loves father and
mother or many other things is not
worthy of me i did not come upon the
earth to bring peace but a sword to cut
away all things depart you from your
sister brother mother child and friend
that in truth are your foes end quote
for whatever is familiar to you is your
foe if your eye wanted to see all things
and your ear to hear all things and your
heart to remember all things then indeed
your soul would be dissipated in all
these things
accordingly a master says to receive an
interior act a man must collect all his
powers as if into a corner of his soul
where hiding away from all images and
forms he can get to work end quote
here he must come to a forgetting and an
unknowing there must be a stillness and
silence for this word to make itself
heard we cannot serve this word better
than in stillness and in silence
there we can hear it and thereto we will
understand it all right in the unknowing
to him who knows nothing it appears and
reveals itself
another question arises you might say
sir you place all our salvation in
ignorance that sounds like a lack god
made man to know as the prophet says
lord make them know where there is
ignorance there is a lack something is
missing a man is brutish an ape a fool
and remains so long as he is ignorant
ah but here we must come to a
transformed knowledge and this unknowing
must not come from ignorance but rather
from knowing we must get to this
unknowing
then we shall become knowing with divine
knowing and our unknowing will be
ennobled and adorned with supernatural
knowing
and through holding ourselves passive in
this we are more perfect than if we were
active
that is why one master declares that the
sense of hearing is nobler than that of
sight for we learn more wisdom by
hearing than by seeing and in it live
the more wisely we hear of a pagan
master who laid dying his disciples
disgust in his presence some noble art
and dying though he was he lifted up his
head to listen saying oh let me hear
this art now that i may rejoice in it
forever
hearing draws in more but seeing rather
leads outward the very act of seeing
does this therefore in eternal life we
shall rejoice far more in our power of
hearing than in that of sight for the
act of hearing the eternal word is
within me but the act of seeing goes
forth from me
in hearing i am passive but in seeing i
am active
but our bliss lies not in our activity
but in being passive to god
for just as god is more excellent than
creatures by so much is god's work more
excellent than mine
it was from his immeasurable love that
god set our happiness in suffering for
we undergo more than we act and receive
incomparably more than we give and each
gift that we receive prepares us to
receive yet another gift indeed a
greater one and every gift further
increases our receptivity and the desire
to receive something yet higher and
greater therefore some teachers say that
is in this respect the soul is
commensurate with god
for just as god is boundless in giving
so too the soul is boundless in
receiving or conceiving
and just as god is omnipotent to act so
too the soul is no less profound to
suffer and thus she is transformed with
god and in god
god must act and the soul must suffer he
must know and love himself in her she
must know with his knowledge and love
with his love and thus she is far more
with what is his than with her own
and so too her bliss is more dependent
on his action than her own
the pupils of saint dionysius asked him
why timothy surpassed them all in
perfection dionysius said timothy is a
god-suffering man whoever is expert at
this could outstrip all men
in this way your unknowing is not a lack
but your chief perfection and your
suffering is your highest activity
and so in this way you must cast aside
all your deeds and silence your
faculties if you really wish to
experience this birth in you
if you would find the newborn king you
must outstrip and abandon all else that
you might find that we may outstrip and
cast behind us all things unpleasing to
the newborn king may he help us who
became a human child in order that we
might become the children of god
amen
so that was the sermon by meister
eckhart i hope you found it
as fascinating as i do it really like i
said in the beginning he really
barely mentions the human jesus uh in
this at all it's just he goes completely
and directly into the deep metaphysical
thought
about this the ground of god and the
soul and how the sun is born inside the
ground of the soul and all this
uh and and he really expresses a lot of
those fundamental and central aspects of
his philosophical and mystical thought
in this sermon in ways that i just think
is so clever and very fascinating
uh so
as i said also i think regardless of
your religious affiliation i think we
can
appreciate from a historical perspective
uh the the skill
of maester eckhart and his sermons
the sermons were held in german in
vernacular language was which was also
quite unique at that point many of the
great church figures express themselves
exclusively in latin but eckhart would
write and preach a lot in middle high
german which is what makes him really
fascinating
anyway i hope that was a interesting and
thought-provoking little christmas
episode so to wrap up
in whatever way you celebrate the
holiday season if you celebrate
christmas if you
celebrate the solstice that took place a
few days ago
if you celebrated hanukkah recently
whatever i hope you have a wonderful
holiday season and a merry christmas and
happy new year i hope to see you in a
the next video very soon i'll see you
then
[Music]
you